في جمهورية أفريقيا الوسطى،
أصبحت رسالة فاغنر واضحة، حيث أن
عملها كالمعتاد بعد
أقل من شهر من
مقتل رئيسهم يفغيني بريغوسيان في حادث
تحطم طائرة، لا يزال المرتزقة يحرسون
الرئيس ويشكلون شخصية مخيفة
في شوارع العاصمة
وجوههم مغطاة  ينص بروتوكول فاغنر على
أنهم لا يمكن الاقتراب منهم ولا
يمكن المساس بهم، وهذه هي الصور الأولى
لمقاتلي فاغنر في البلاد منذ
وفاة بريغوسيان، لذلك من الواضح أنهم لا
يزالون موجودين إلى حد كبير، حيث أن
وجودهم عميق، والأسواق
مليئة بأكياس الفودكا والبيرة الرخيصة التي
يصنعها  شركة مملوكة لشركة فاغنر،
يبدو أن السكان المحليين يحبون
البيرة الروسية فقط. لقد
عدنا إلى مركز
إمبراطورية بريغوسيان في أفريقيا، حيث أن
وفاته تثير تساؤلات حول
الأنظمة التي كان يحميها والمرتزقة
الذين ألهم ولائهم،
وكانت زيارتنا الأخيرة في فاغنر
الأيام الأولى هنا تجري مثل المافيا التي تقدم
الأسلحة والمقاتلين والدعاية
مقابل الذهب والماس والأخشاب
باستخدام الترهيب والوحشية على طول
الطريق
تلك السيارة المليئة بالروس كانت
تلاحقنا لبعض الوقت ولا نعرف لماذا
لا نعرف  ما يريدون
ولكن في هذه الحرب الخارجة على القانون، البلد الذي مزقته الحرب،
أحد أفقر البلدان في العالم، حيث
يحتفل الكثيرون بالقسوة والأمن الذي جلبته،
هذا هو القميص تمامًا، نعم،
تي شيرت جميل،
يقول المستشار الرئاسي فيدل جوانجيكا إن
الأمة في حالة تأهب  الحداد على
زعيم فاغنر الميت، لقد كان صديقي، وكان صديقي
المفضل، وصديقًا لجميع
سكان أفريقيا الوسطى، لماذا بالضبط كان
السيد بريجوسيان يتمتع بشعبية كبيرة هنا في
عقلك لأن بلدنا،
لذا ألست متوترًا الآن بعد أن مات
وأن الأمور قد تتغير  اتصل السيد بوتين
برئيسنا
وأخبره أن كل شيء سيكون مثل
الأمس ولن يتغير
شيء،
ولكن وفقًا لمصدر دبلوماسي
هنا، غادر المئات من مقاتلي فاغنر
جمهورية إفريقيا الوسطى في يوليو
بعد فشل الباغوسيين في التمرد،
ومن بقي منهم بما في ذلك كبار
مساعديه  تم الاتفاق على العمل لصالح
وزارة الدفاع الروسية، وقد تم
بالفعل سحب المقاتلين من
المواقع الأمامية إلى المراكز السكانية
في محاولة لخفض التكاليف. يقول المصدر إن
ما هو أقل وضوحًا هو ما سيصبح
الوجود المدني لفاغنر هنا، وهذا هو
أحد الأماكن الأخيرة التي تتواجد فيها بريغوزيان.
شوهد على قيد الحياة خلال جولته الأخيرة
عبر أفريقيا ويسمى
المركز الثقافي الروسي فقط، وليس له أي
صلة بالوكالة الثقافية الرسمية الروسية وكان
يديره حتى وقت قريب
أقرب مساعدي بريغوسيان هنا
تظهر الصور التي التقطت في تلك الزيارة
وجهًا جديدًا لامرأة تعرف باسم نفيسة
كيريانوفا
بعد أيام من طلب الإذن بالزيارة،
قررنا التصوير سرًا، لكنك
كنت هنا، وعندما
كان هنا في الصور، هناك
صور لك معي أثناء الذهاب
معًا يا
إلهي، هل يمكنك أن تريني ذلك، نعم،
أعتقد أنه كان كذلك  في تلك الزاوية،
نعم،
كيف كان حاله، هل
تعتقد أنه كان يعلم أنهم
سيقتلونه
يا إلهي، إنه
هناك من يعرف مثل هذه الأشياء
ماذا يعني لعملك هنا،
هل يغير أي شيء، هل يغير
أي شيء إذا لم أفعل ذلك.  لا أعرف أن رئيس
اليابان يعني وجود ثلاث خطوات لكرة السلة،
فهي تعرض لنا أحد
دروس اللغة الروسية اليومية بينما نعود إلى
الخارج نرى مقاتلًا من فاغنر،
يمكنك فقط جعله يتراجع إلى
الجزء الخلفي من المركز حيث وفقًا
لـ  تبيع مجموعة التحقيق في القرن
فاغنر الذهب والماس
لكبار الشخصيات وتدير عمليات الأخشاب والكحول الخاصة بها، هل
يمكن لأي شخص أن يرى ما هو هناك، وهذا غريب
في الواقع، أو ما الذي
ستراه هناك مثل معظم
أنشطة فاغنر هنا، فمن الواضح أنه
لا يزال هناك  لقد تم إخفاء الكثير عن الأنظار، لقد
دفعنا الزيارة إلى حد كافٍ وحان
الوقت للذهاب بغض النظر عمن
يتولى المسؤولية هنا.
يقول الدبلوماسيون الغربيون إنهم لا يتوقعون الكثير من
التغيير في الكنيسة الأرثوذكسية المحلية،
وقد تم رسم الحروف اليونانية على
ولائها  الآن هو النظام الأبوي الروسي
وحتى في السماء فوق الإمبراطورية التي
بنتها بريغوسي، تعيش هيمنة روسيا
على كلاريسا وارد CNN bongi